scarring of the liver was once thought
to be an irreversible situation but a
new and exciting field of experimental
drugs may put an end to this Dogma the
liver is a large smooth organ that
carries out many essential functions it
stores and releases nutrients aids
digestion and breaks down unwanted
substances
unfortunately numerous chronic diseases
damage the liver and when they continue
for a long time they cause scarring a
condition called fibrosis the most
common causes are hepatitis viruses long
term heavy drinking and fatty liver
disease associated with obesity and
diabetes this scarring is caused by a
buildup of fibrous collagen proteins
which begin to replace healthy tissue
if the fibrosis keeps worsening the
liver can progress to a state known as
cirrhosis at this stage excessive
scarring hampers delivers blood flow and
stops it being able to do its job
unchecked cirrhosis can be directly to
liver failure and puts patients at high
risk for liver cancer cirrhosis
currently kills a million people
worldwide each year the good news is
that the liver has its own mechanisms
that degrade scar tissue and this
discovery has spurred a new wave of
research into developing drugs which can
halt the progression of fibrosis or
speed up healing once the underlying
disease has been treated the best way to
reduce fibrosis is to avoid it
altogether by removing the risk factors
associated with the disease but now
scientists are examining the biology of
the scar causing cells as potential
targets for therapeutic interventions
scars are generated by cells called
myofibril busts when these cells become
activated they proliferate migrate to
injury sites and secrete collagen into
the extracellular matrix as these
collagen fibers accumulates they become
cross-linked into a mesh which stiffens
the tissue and blocks its function so
researchers are aiming their sites first
and foremost at Myo fibroblasts one
strategy is to target the messenger
molecules which coordinate their
activation these are released by damaged
liver cells and immune cells and could
targeted by new drugs one example is a
drug called Seneca River rock that
blocks receptors for pro fibrosis
messengers called cytokines another set
of drugs could inactivate Maya
fibroblasts by targeting receptors on
their surface called integrins that
allow them to interact with other cells
and the extracellular matrix multiple
drugs that work this way are currently
being explored and will enter human
trials soon blocking the Maya
fibroblasts ability to make collagen is
another option these drugs work by
inserting small bits of RNA into the
nucleus of Maya fibroblasts
destabilizing the machinery that creates
collagen fibers another approach is to
block the enzymes that cross-linked
collagen fibers to stiffen the scar
matrix
this makes the collagen easier for the
body to degrade finally an exciting new
avenue is the use of cell therapies
introducing extra immune cells called
macrophages into rodents livers strongly
boosts the organs intrinsic anti
scarring mechanisms and now human trials
using patient's own macrophages have
begun all these therapies will require
clinical trials and due to the slow
progressive nature of liver fibrosis
this may take years but new biomarkers
in development may speed up trials
considerably by showing whether the
drugs are working
even before the overall fibrosis starts
to decline hopefully these new
approaches will help us to victory in
the scar Wars
you